[Music]
even with the bottomless budget and a
bunch of a-list stars at disney's
disposal
the pirates of the caribbean movies may
be pretty great
but they're still not perfect set over
the course of several years during the
18th century
this swashbuckler epic series has fallen
victim to a number of historical
inaccuracies
though they pale in comparison to the
many rookie mistakes
made on the set and in the editing room
from glaring errors in continuity to
make up mishaps
and green screen nightmares here are the
biggest mistakes
lurking in the pirates of the caribbean
movies
jack's escape in the curse of the black
pearl when captain jack sparrow is
repaid for saving elizabeth's life with
a rest
the captain engineers the first of what
would become many improbable escapes
over the course of the franchise
after putting a pistol to the head of
miss swan and ordering her to unshackle
him
sparrow grabs a rope and releases the
cannon at the other end
flying into a spin and eventually to
freedom
before departing he tells commodore
norrington
gentlemen you will always remember this
as the day that you almost caught
captain jack in reality
we would remember it as the day his men
time traveled into the future to upgrade
their weapons
the english gunman fire at will each
popping off
shot after shot though rifles at the
time would have needed reloading after
every bullet
repeating rifles like these didn't come
into use until 1862
when they were used by union soldiers
during the american civil war
still this movie does have pirate
zombies so maybe
time travel isn't totally out of the
question
elven tattoo in another black pearl
blunder
all round do-gooder will turner engages
in an acrobatic jewel
that utilizes all the machinery in the
blacksmith shop to stop sparrow from
escaping
when he leans over to taunt jack he
exposes a rather unusual tattoo for
1700s port royal
bonnie's forearm in black ink is the
word 9. in j.r.r
tolkien's elvish tengwa script a piece
he and a number of his castmates had
done to commemorate their time working
together on
the lord of the rings orlando bloom took
instagram to share an old photo of the
gang showing off their matching tats the
day they got them done
that's all well and good for orlando
bloom super cool actor guy
but will turner seems like too much of a
square to get a tattoo
even for something as nerdy as lord of
the rings
maybe they should have covered that
thing with some makeup
the lonely cowboy the sheer number of
people needed to bring a big budget
franchise film to life
means it can get a little crowded
sometimes even on the largest of sets
separating the extras from the many crew
members needed to turn a ship
into a working film set clearly proved
to be too much of a challenge here
there's a lot of movement on deck when
jack sparrow finally returns to the helm
of this beloved ship
and the final cut of the curse of the
black pearl relies on this to keep you
blind from the obvious error in the
scene for just
a single frame a man dressed in a modern
white t-shirt and tan cowboy hat
can be seen over captain jack's shoulder
staring longingly out to sea
as the film goes on around him he
probably misses his horse
[Music]
disappearing fish guts in dead man's
chest when will boards the dutchman in
search of his father his rescue mission
fails to go as planned
cursed mutineer bootstrap bill turner is
bound to davy jones as a member of his
immortal crew
having agreed to serve a hundred years
aboard his ship
and the supernatural tyrant has no
intention of breaking that contract
will is set upon by jones gruesome crew
slicing one of his attackers open
as he advances and spilling fishy guts
all over the deck
when the young turner is knocked down
seconds later however
all those guts have pretty much vanished
this is either an
obvious continuity error or producers
making sure that orlando bloom's highly
marketable face
wouldn't be covered in rotten intestines
even for a brief moment
tortuga concertina the tortuga bar fight
is pretty much
everything you could want out of drunken
pirates punching each other
it begins with the disheveled james
norrington applying to serve under the
very pirate he once chased halfway
across the world
and it ends with this shamed commodore
getting a bottle smashed over his head
the music playing over the all-out brawl
that takes place in between those two
events
comes from a concertina one of the most
piratey sounding instruments there is
have a listen
even though that tune really fits the
scene well its inclusion is pretty
factually inaccurate
the concertina a cousin of the accordion
wasn't actually invented until the next
century
around 1830. still there's never really
a bad time for a solid concertina jam
[Music]
the big wheel the most memorable dead
man's chess scene might be the big
wheel run in which a sword fight between
norrington
and turner ends up becoming a whole new
disney park ride in the making
jack sparrow also finds himself caught
up in the wheel as it rolls downhill
towards the ocean
though he's thrown out again before long
knocked out by a metal bar that
from all other angles looks to be a good
foot above the captain's head
that isn't the biggest mistake in the
scene however when the wheel finally
slows to a stop it falls to the left
with the axle pointing down
when norrington and turner emerge the
wheel is somehow the other way up
with the axle pointing skyward the
self-repairing ship
davey jones ferry to the afterlife the
flying dutchman
is the most formidable ship to have
appeared in the franchise thus far
rising from the deep and making
matchsticks out of the navy and pirate
vessels alike
as jones bears down on jack sparrow's
black pearl in pursuit of his stolen
heart
he orders his crew send his beloved pile
back to the tents and they get to work
on sinking the pearl the windows of the
captain's quarters and the wood framing
them is blown to pieces by the
dutchman's cannons
though sparrow's ship seems to have some
other worldly qualities of its own
either that or it's just a really bad
edit
moments later viewing the pearl from the
port side of the dutchman
we see that its back end has magically
repaired itself
maybe somebody came in here and fixed it
or something
someone like an angel jack's rings
you know how it was weird that will
turner had a lord of the rings tattoo
maybe it does make sense when you
consider the jack sparrow has magic
rings of his own the captain is left
alone as the mythical kraken wraps its
giant tentacles around his pride and joy
all while he's chained to the mast of
his doomed ship however
to the surprise of absolutely nobody
jack manages to escape
using lamp oil to wriggle his hand free
of his manacle
as he does the rings on his index and
ring fingers
come loose and are just about to pop
right off until jack whips his hand free
with the same ring somehow still in
place
the fountain of youth as at world's end
draws to a close
jack discovers that his old nemesis
babosa
has once again taken the pearl though
he's able to continue his search for the
fountain of youth without it
as sparrows sets out from tortuga on his
dinghy
we see him consulting a scroll that
details the discovery of
aqua de veda by someone named ponce de
leon
in 1523 history buffs no
this refers to an actual spanish
explorer and conquistador
who according to legend set sail in
search of the mythical fountain
the trouble is this voyage actually took
place in the year
1513 not 1523 as jack's map states
so close tire tracks the fourth
installment in the franchise
2011s on stranger tides begins with jack
making a failed attempt to free his
first mate
joshumi gibbs who's being held in london
on charges of piracy
captured sparrow is brought before king
george ii
who asks him to join his expedition to
find the fountain of youth
he of course refuses and as always makes
an unconventional escape
as the hunt for sparrow moves into the
streets of the british capital
which is filled with skinny wheeled
buggies pulled by horses
tire tracks made by a modern car or
truck are visible in the mud
as clear as day the shrinking imposter
jack soon finds out that an impostor has
been attempting to put together a crew
to lead an expedition to find the
fountain under his name
when sparrow comes face to face with
said imposter
the pair become involved in a sword
fight that keeps the identity of the
captain's foe hidden
until the very last moment the fake jack
turns out to be
angelica his former lover and the
daughter of infamous pirate
captain blackbeard who also happens to
be seeking the mythical fountain
the problem with this scene is the
height difference between penelope cruz
and whoever stood in for her during the
battle as this person was
clearly the same height if not a little
taller than johnny depp
meanwhile cruz is clearly a few inches
shorter
than depp even in heels half cocked
blackbeard sparrow has various run-ins
with blackbeard over the course of
on stranger tights as the pair go
head-to-head in a battle of
savvy shanghaied into service aboard his
vessel the queen anne's revenge
jack fails in an attempted mutiny and
sees first-hand the power of
blackbeard's legendary sword of trident
a magic blade that allows the wielder to
control every rope and pulley on the
ship
you dare face
this sword but his closest
shave with blackbeard comes on land when
jack finds himself with his back to a
cliff and
a gun to his face a closer look reveals
that sparrow isn't
actually in that much danger at all
seeing his blackbeard has his pistol
half cocked and it wouldn't fire no
matter how hard he squeezed the trigger
barbosa's lieutenant commander the
revealed that barbosa was alive and well
minus one leg perhaps wasn't unexpected
nor was the fact that the black pearl
had been lost
under his command seeing as he seems to
lose control of the ship
as often as jack does the biggest
surprise was that captain barbosa was
now in the employ
of the crown though either the former
pirate isn't up to scratch with his navy
lingo
or the rad has made a few historical
errors
barbosa addresses one of his men as
lieutenant commander
a rank that was not introduced into the
royal navy until
1914. also his ship flies a version of
the union jack flag
that didn't exist at the time as the
kingdom of ireland
had yet to be absorbed magic feathers
poor jeffrey rush was done yet another
disservice later in the movie
this time by the editing department with
his ridiculous wig
left back on land he sheds the rest of
his british
naval garb after admitting to jack that
his true goal
was to exact revenge on blackbeard for
sinking the pearl and taking his leg in
the process the scene in which a young
deckhand passes him a hat
more suited to his true standing as a
pirate is supposed to be a moment for
the character
but instead it leaves viewers asking
where the hell did those feathers come
from
maybe he was getting ready to set sail
for the player haters ball after all
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love too